So, that’s all I’d like to say about Path Links for
now. Next I want to focus for a little while on the
notion of a clustering coefficient. Now, you might
be less familiar with this notion of clustering
coefficient than you are with paths and graphs, so
let’s go through how this is often defined.
What the clustering coefficient is trying to capture is,
as I said before, cliquishness. How likely is it that
two nodes that are connected are part of some kind
of larger highly connected group of nodes? So one
typical way of defining the clustering coefficient is to
start-off by taking about the clustering coefficient for
a particular node in a graph, I’m going to generalize
this to clustering coefficients for the entire graph
next, but let’s focus on a single node. So say, V is
that node and Kv is its degree and Nv of V is the
number of links between the neighbors of V. So, let’s
look at this example graph to ground out some of
these concepts. So here we’ve got graph, let’s call
this node V. Could point to any of them but I’m going
to go with this one. Let’s take a look at the neighbors
of V. Those are the nodes that are directly
connected to V in the graph. We’ve got this one, and
this one, and this one, and this one. So the number
of those neighbors is exactly the degree of V, which
in this case is 4. And now let’s look at the links
between these neighbors of V. So, there is this one
that goes between the two pink nodes and that
seems to be it. This node isn’t connected to any
other pink node. This one is not connected to any
other pink node. This is not connected to any pink
node and so on. So in this case, Nv is 1. And we are
going to combine these quantities together as
follows. We take twice the number of neighbor links
divided by the degree of V times one minus the
degree of V. Now, this may look a little odd but let’s
compute what it is and then I’ll explain it. So in this
case, two times Nv just one, divided by K times K
minus one. So it’s four times three. And the result we
get in this case for this particular V is 1/6. So what
this represents is actually the fraction of possible
interconnections between the neighbors of V. So,
because it’s a fraction, we’re expecting it to be
something between zero and one. And in fact we
can get zero if we’ve got something that’s like a star.
So V has edges going out but none of those connect
to each other. And it can actually be all the way to
one if we have a cleek. So V is connected to its
neighbors and all the neighbors are connected to
each other. So that’s why this formula has the form
that it does, Kv times Kv minus one all divided by
two is the maximum number of connections among a
set of nodes of size Kv. So, we take the reciprocal of
that multiplied by Nv that gives us the fraction that
we’re looking for. So, in this case V is a sixth, it’s you
know a six of the way from being a star to being a
cleek. So it’s not that tightly connected and in fact
you know that sort of what we saw as well that V is
connected to a bunch of neighbors but they are not
really connected to each other all that much. I am
going to say that the clustering coefficient for graph
is just the average of the clustering coefficients of
the nodes in the graph. So if we wanted to compute
the clustering coefficient of this graph, we’d actually
have to go through node, to node, to node, to node,
to node, to node, to node, compute the clustering
coefficient for each one and then average.